hello everyone I don't know if you heard
of McHale asleep oh he's a
three-year-old chess prodigy from Russia
and I think it's quickly becoming one of
my favorite chess players in the world
as this game was played in 2016 so last
year and the three-year-old Misha is
playing against former world champion
Anatoly Karpov they organized this match
just to see how talented the kid really
is and they do consider him to be the
most talented chess prodigy to ever live
so and the this game was played I mean
the conditions weren't really fit for a
three-year-old I mean they played on the
stage and the audience was huge
you had the commentator everything was
flashy you know lots of lights and this
was a blitz game so it's it's a lot to
take to take in you know for a
three-year-old but he managed to hold
his own and to play a decent game
although well you just see young Misha
is white and Anatoly Karpov is black we
have d4 Knight to f6 c4 by Misha East
690 c3 Bishop to b4 and we have a three
the nimzo-indian defense Bishop captures
on c3v captures on c3 and now c5 and
this is all standard theory and here
some players would prefer Knight to f3
some would play III some would play
Queen to c2 but the three-year-old
prodigy plays a move that simply stands
Karpov
he plays D captures in c5 and he
voluntarily triples his pawns and here
well Karpov was a bit surprised and well
okay he plays Knight to a6 and going for
that c5 pawn as well they are tripled
but the young ameesha simply continues
to develop a Bishop to g5 we have Knight
captures on c5 and we have Knight to f3
and ok black is somewhat better here he
has a better pawn structure but it's
nothing serious you know the the
three-year-old is holding his own
we have be 6 by Karpov g3
we have h6 attacking the bishop Bishop
captures on f6 we have Queen captures on
f6 and out Knights the d4 as carpel was
threatening to capture this pawn and c3
put a fork on the king in the rook so
934 we have bishop
be seven by Karpov attacking the rook
and in this position young Misha plays
the strongest move recommended by the
engine and like I said this is a bliss
game and he is three years old and he
plays f3
we have castles by Karpov and Bishop the
g2 also the strongest move we have
Bishop to a6 and now Karpov leaves this
strong diagonal and goes for this c4
pawn and young Misha immediately takes
advantage of this he plays f4 now
expanding on the King side and also now
creating a discovered attack here on the
rock on a 8 carpet plays rook a to c8
and we have castles by young Misha
Bishop captures on c4 and here well like
I said the conditions weren't really
ideal for for a three-year-old and there
were always you know they were asking
him questions and they were talking a
lot so he was losing a lot a lot of time
you know just on things that really did
to chess and here he did spend a lot of
time and he played f5 Karpov immediately
responded with E 5 we had a knife to f3
and here Karpov played d5 and here young
Misha was still thinking and in this
position well his flag fell he ran out
of time and Karpov informed his young
young adversary that he lost in time and
it was at this moment that young Misha
went into tears and started crying and
calling for his mother but then his
mother said oh it's ok make sure
everything's okay and Karpov presented
him with a huge metal and said that he
he earned that he was a he's a great
player and well then everything was ok
again and then young Misha went on to
solve some puzzles some chess puzzles
and he solved a couple of puzzles and he
like really destroyed them and it's like
mating to mate in three and he he solves
them instantly and I will put a link in
the description below where you can see
a video of this event and do check the
game and do check how young Misha
destroys the puzzles at the end of that
video and it's simply amazing and this
year young Misha actually
won a game against the Grandmaster he he
beat Yuri over Bach and Yuri over buck
is 95 years old okay but still a four
year old defeated a legendary Grand
Master I mean it was it was Michael Todd
who actually want his Grandmaster title
and when he defeated Yuri over back on
time using the Belgrade gambit with the
white pieces so I mean he's definitely a
strong Grandmaster he did overlook a
piece but nevertheless a four-year-old
managed to defeat a grandmaster so yeah
they're definitely an amazing kid and
definitely want to want to look out for
I think we can definitely expect great
things from from young young Misha so
yeah I will put I will make the video
about the game against you Yuri over
back as well and I do hope you enjoyed
this video and I would like to thank
Corbin Johnson pierre-louis channel
gunner wolf and the theater weights for
our contributions to my channel I really
appreciate it and yeah that's it thank
y'all for watching as usual you can
check two of my previous videos here and
I'll see you soon